eduardo core y está preocupado su suegro
se encuentra grave y no puede internarlo
en un hospital 23 pacientes que están en
espera de cambio y uno debe ser era mi
suelo que estaba ahí
así estas abandonos en la cambia en el
país están los pacientes los hospitales
del perú están desbordados por pacientes
del joven 19 que en medio de esta crisis
los médicos llevan más de dos semanas de
huelga indefinida exigen mayor inversión
en el sector salud gremio el sector está
colapsando propuesto al borde de un
colapso queda un poco margen para poder
reaccionar como sistema sanitario en
este en esta segunda ola y es el colapso
afecta no sólo la falta de camas en
salas críticas sino el recurso humano el
presidente francisco se haga así ha
ordenado el retorno a la cuarentena en
10 regiones del perú y aseguró que se
mejorará la atención de la emergencia
sanitaria estamos ampliando el número de
camas uci se han incorporado 196 camas
en las últimas dos semanas y se añadirán
350 más en las próximas dos semanas para
los ciudadanos en busca del oxígeno que
pueda salvar a sus familiares
la promesa es el presidente se haga así
suenan como palabras vacías como muchos
cristian valiente tuvo que ausentarse de
su trabajo
carl el gas medicinal que su madre de 80
años necesita para respirar por eso
estamos desesperados viviendo de
diferentes distritos para conseguir eso
no que lo más primordial
tras tres días de espera y un largo
viaje a las afueras de ánima cristian
retorna a su hogar
él espera no contagiarse de el
coronavirus para seguir luchando por la
vida de su madre